Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
Today we're going to be discussing the
fall of the Roman empire and the Dark
Ages that subsequently and Gulfs Europe.
Some questions we must address and
this documentary are of course,
what caused the mighty
Roman Empire to collapse.
What was life like in the dark ages?
How dark? Where are they really?
And if they were rather dark,
what made them this way?
What did people hold onto throughout
them and how did Europe eventually climb
out of them?
This video today is made possible by
the patriotic support of Chris Yates,
so thank you again Chris. Now,
then let's get to it. Rome,
one 17 and the year of the death of
the emperor Trajan who building on the
efforts of his predecessors,
which at this time spend over 800
years expanded the Roman Empire to its
pinnacle. While there is
still conflict on the borders,
which other strong emperors who
succeed Trajan that same century,
such as Hadrian and Marcus Aurelius,
well pursue the empire itself is still
in an age of prosperity and relative
peace known as Pax Romana,
the Roman peace.
This is the glorious Roman Empire
with which we are all familiar,
though was still sand for centuries to
come and while it was still in the middle
of its golden age, the seeds of
catastrophe will soon be planted.
In one 77 the son of Marcus Aurelius
comedies became emperor communists,
broke the chain of strong emperors,
which Rome had been enjoying that century.
He was foolish, cowardly, inept,
and outright sociopathic and insane.
He ordered his guards to dance naked.
He drank in public while
dress like a woman.
He had hundreds of female
and male sex slaves,
but what really angered the Roman elites
known as patricians were things like
human sacrifice,
mutilating innocent people.
And of course his participation in
gladiator fights in these mock fights,
he would often take on
amputees and very brutal way.
Just as an example of how he
would fight during this rain,
the Roman statesmen Cassius Deo would
claim the competence because the Rome to
descend from a kingdom of
goal to one of rust and iron.
And indeed many historians agree
that roams very slowed down.
Fall begins with the reign of comedies.
This went on for years until communist
was finally killed by being strangled
while bathing the Senate that pretended
to love him while he was alive.
Basically we decided to make him a public
enemy once he died and tried to wipe
out his memory altogether. Communists
was not the first lunatic emperor.
The most famous example in Roman history
was of course Caligula who did things
like make us horse a priest and ordered
his soldiers to stab the see and collect
seashells as war trophies when he
declared war on the God Neptune.
These things are of course funding to
us 2000 years later but also very sad
because these were quite clearly very
mentally ill people who are placed in
positions that allowed them to cause a
lot of damage and they were to the Romans
at the time.
Very scary.
Obviously with Caligula the Romans had
whether these types of things before,
but there was not much relief
following communist his death.
Much more common than insane.
Emperors and statesmen and Rome
were corrupt and self serving ones.
Though plenty of both kinds
would come and as centuries,
which followed the year of the five
emperors would follow his reign.
Person x, a military leader was made
emperor by the Praetorian Guard,
but then the guard killed
him within three months.
Didas you Leanna's succeeded him
by buying the position actually,
but then he was executed two months later.
Civil war in Rome then broke
out between two other claimants,
Septimius Severus and per skinniest.
Niger Septimius would win this
war and rule for almost 18 years.
But following him was a succession of
other corrupt and inept emperors and in
fact, corrupt and inept officials
across the empire in general.
So essentially,
while the rule of communists and the year
of the five emperors may have been an
unusually desperate time for Rome,
it did set the stage for other
similar behaviors to follow.
Things did not improve in a
third century as Rome entered.
What is remembered as a crisis of
the third century during this period,
along with the aforementioned
style of rural being commonplace,
civil war ravaged and divided,
the empire foreign armies attacked it.
The economy took a major downfall.
There was a 13 year plague and many
other trouble is plagued Rome if people
hadn't realized it before.
They definitely were now
starting to realize that Rome
wasn't trouble and indeed
people were concerned that they were
facing a complete collapse of the empire,
if not the end of the world.
Intuity for Diocletian became emperor.
Diocletian was a low status soldier born
and modern day Croatia that rose to the
ranks of the military and
eventually became emperor by
defeating other claimants.
Diocletian was the first strong
emperor Roman seen in quite awhile.
You recognize that Rome was in major
trouble and intended to reinvigorate the
empire. We've discussed already some of
the things that were leading to and would
eventually finally lead to Rome's
collapse entirely foreign invasion,
civil war and other domestic
struggles for power, economic turmoil,
et Cetera,
or remedy.
Diocletian would come to would be to
split the empire between the East and the
West. Rome was a giant empire
even by today's standards,
it stretched from Scotland to
the Persian Gulf. Naturally,
if the empire turned his attention toward
one end of it, Scotland for example,
then this would give someone in Egypt
and opportunity to seize control for
themselves or cause some kind of chaos
in an age when word traveled slowly and
people in armies much slower Diocletian
that suggested that the empire remain
one single Roman empire but be divided
administratively between East and west
with two emperors.
Furthermore,
Diocletian would break the 50 or so Roman
provinces into over a hundred to ease
administration of those as well.
These were generally successful or forums,
at least temporarily. Many other
reforms such as expanding the army,
raising taxes to support that army,
trying to stop inflation and persecuting
Christians were not effective and many
were in fact rather harmful.
He had also tried to stop civil war as
a means by which new emperor is came to
power though after his reign.
This method once again became commonplace.
Admirably.
Diocletian was the first Roman emperor
to voluntarily resign living out his
retirement,
growing cabbages at his home until he
died in three 11 eight while splitting the
empire helped administratively
financially it was a bad call.
The western empire was less wealthy
but had more financial burdens,
namely supporting the military against
numerous enemies and you know the
constant warfare.
Furthermore,
as expansion halted over the
late second and third centuries,
the western economy which relied heavily
on slave labor from conquered peoples
started to suffer more as well.
With fever slaves obviously available.
The wealth of the western empire became
increasingly concentrated in the elite.
Meanwhile,
the lower classes struggled increasingly
leading to a loss of cohesion and
society. This along with other
factors such as religious intolerance,
specifically toward Jews and much more
so the rising religion Christianity and
what many Romans saw as a degradation of
their values would lead to a breakdown
of the Romans sense of community.
It would be an emperor named Constantine
the great that would attempt to solve
many of these issues while fighting and
yet another civil war for the throne and
the early fourth century Constantine
claim to have received one of the most
important messages in history and a sky
he saw across a Christian symbol and
heard the words in Hawk signal.
We get by this sign you shall conquer.
He then claimed to have a dream in which
he was visited by Christ where he was
commanded a fight with the Cairo sign,
another Christian symbol.
He did so and in the battle of the million
bridge defeated his opponents army,
which outnumber at him two to one.
This would go down in history as one
of the most important battles that were
fought.
Constantine would enter Rome victoriously
and with later issue the edict of
Milan along with the
eastern emperor lie sinneas.
This essentially allowed the worship
of Christianity and all other religions
across the empire,
thus ending centuries of persecution.
It also grants it back to Christian's
all the lens which had been taken during
Diocletian's persecution.
Later Constantine with the feet lies
sinneas in war and become emperor of both
the West and the east. He was then
found a new capital of the east,
replaced a Greek pagan capital,
which symbolize vision.
He would build a city on top of an
older city called Byzantium and named it
after himself.
Constantinople for the more constant team,
would help Christians organize the
Catholic church to its modern form.
Contrary to popular belief,
Constantine did not immediately
convert to Christianity. In fact,
he spent most of his life
officially as a pagan,
sort of bouncing around with and working
on both religions and drawing symbols
from both of them and that sort of thing,
but towards the end of his life,
he would convert to Christianity. Becoming
a first Christian emperor of Rome,
thereby shocking much of the world.
It would not be long,
perhaps only 60 years or so after
Constantine's death that most of Rome
converted to Christianity as well.
In fact, about 80% of the empire.
This was a huge change and the effects
of Constantine's rural are still with us
today.
Was Christianity,
however beneficial to saving Rome
or did it hasten its downfall?
There is debate.
Some scholars argue that it led to a
breakdown of traditional Roman values.
Others argued that traditional
Roman values we're already
breaking down and that
Christianity gave Romans and new
necessary focal point in their lives.
Regardless,
however of the state religion,
Rome still had other problems to
face throughout the fourth century.
The barbarians became a
bigger and bigger problem.
This along with increasing
financial difficulties,
more inept neps leadership
after Constantine the great
or read a vision of the
empire and other problems started
this spelled trouble for Rome.
In the fourth century,
barbarians began encroaching on Roman
territory and settling and parts of it and
Rome often lack the
ability to remove them.
Eventually Romans began integrating more
and more barbarian soldiers into their
armies to maintain their empire.
These soldiers were cheaper
but have less loyalty as well.
Typically they had no actual
concern for Rome itself,
only for their barbarian commander and
their people and of course only cared
about their personal gain from being in
the army in the late fourth and early
fifth century.
A group known as the hung's from the
Eurasian steppes began moving Westburg
displacing many dramatic tribes.
These dramatic tribes
primarily gos in turn,
began pushing into Rome putting
more strain on Rome as well.
The goths were brought
in to the Roman empire,
but were largely exploited and left
to starve, causing them to rebel.
In three 76 this was when
Rome started the face serious,
irreparable damage.
The Romans would eventually win this war,
but it would be a pyrrhic victory as the
Romans had lost a considerable amount
and couldn't valance the emperor of the
east following this war would be to more
civil wars,
which the emperor Theodosius was struggled
to win Theodosius die in three 95 the
last, the ruler of both the east and
western Roman empire his sons had and our
[inaudible] would succeed him,
but they were essentially also inept
rulers getting the throne of a fractured
empire.
A gothic leader Alaric would lead another
rebellion when the sons of the emperor
Theodosius failed to give
him much opportunity of
advancement in the Roman army
in which she was serving her.
Nori is failed to adequately
respond to the situation,
and it was a general Silico who was
responsible for much of Rome's defense.
As in fact,
Alaric marched on the city of Rome
itself still at co would defend Rome and
other parts of the crumbling empire,
but it would be excessively difficult.
He pulled troops out of Britain and urged
his soldiers to bring those slaves to
fight with them, and four oh
eight still a co a threat to her.
Norris has power was executed,
thus died.
One of the last great Romans Alaric
moved into Italy towards Rome.
His forces were starving
and he needed food.
Though the Romans had little
themselves in for 10 80 Alaric sack,
the city of Rome, the great city
had now fallen to barbarians.
Many truly believed that the end of the
world to come it is said that when the
emperor Norris, who was living in
the city of Ravenna heard the news,
he cried out and yet it had
just eaten from my hands.
He apparently thought that they meant
his favorite chicken named the Roma was
what had perished. Roma is, as I'm sure
you can tell, the Latin word for Rome,
and when he learned it was a city instead,
he was relieved.
This just goes to show how out of touch
with reality high norjes really was and
in fact,
many Roman politicians and aristocrats
were completely out of touch and it came
at one of the worst possible times
Alaric and his Visigoths banning the fine
much food in Rome left
for greener pastures.
Throughout the next few
decades of barbarian tribes
began settling and Hispana
per Tanya Gall,
north Africa and other parts of the empire
and the Romans were largely powerless
to remove them and in fact negotiated
ways to peacefully integrate them.
Barbarian tribes,
again,
primarily Visigoths would ally themselves
with Rome to Repel Attila the hun and
his forces,
but when he was given back and died
unexpectedly and four 53 conflict was back
on,
ultimately,
the barbarian forces in the Roman army
known as the Federal Rati would unite
under a leader of unknown
ethnic background,
possibly a hun named out Walker and four
76 auto Acker would overthrow the last
Roman emperor,
ironically named Romulus that year.
On September 4th and proclaim
himself king of Italy.
After over a thousand years,
Rome had now officially collapsed Romulus.
Only 16 at the time was allowed to
quietly retire as Rome's light was
extinguished.
A key point to take from the fall of Rome
was that it was not merely the result
of barbarian invasion.
It was firstly a combination of several
factors that we can roam significantly
economically.
There were labor shortages from the
lack of slave labor taxation increased
heavily and the money was the valued
from inflation for the more much this tax
money went to fund the
military and infrastructure
was ignored. Administratively,
the empire definitely over expanded and
the division between the West and east,
which temporarily helped ultimately
would cause a two sides of grow apart
leaving the western empire, which was less
wealthy and had more enemies weakened.
Furthermore, as if administration
of the empire wasn't hard enough,
it was being overseen by a number of
corrupt and self-serving emperors and
elites. A large number of Roman emperors
were assassinated by competitors.
Others had to fight civil wars with the
throne and others having achieved it
behaved selfishly and competently or
sometimes rather like click ula or
communists.
There was a similar situation
of ineptitude and apathy
in the Senate as well and
furthermore,
with the weakened government,
the wealthier class was able to flee to
the countryside and avoid taxation and
participation in the state.
We can even take into consideration the
sudden shift and religion which had an
impact on a sudden shift
in values, beliefs and
perspectives of the Roman people.
Though,
as I said at the debate,
continues as to whether
or not Christianity helped
Rome or hastened it's fall.
It was this society which the barbarian
tribes that would ultimately cause roms.
Downfall found a rather
important distinction, however,
was that they did not all invade
room and a traditional sense.
Rome faced many invasions which crippled
it, especially in later centuries,
but many other incidents viewed as
invasions. We're really revolts.
The gothic wars of
three to 76 for example,
was a revolt on a taken by the Goss who
had been, I don't want to say welcomed,
but legally brought into the empire and
allowed settle Alaric and not a slacker,
weren't foreign invaders.
They were both Latin speaking
members of the Roman army,
but they and their soldiers were at
barbarian and origin and had no real
connection to the empire beyond the
superficial opportunity that they saw as
migraines while fleeing from the huns and
thus with the fall of the Roman Empire
Europe.
And while the Western world in general
really falls into what historians call
the early Middle Ages or the dark ages.
But while the dark ages are
painted as a regressive, unstable,
and archaic, fearful, primitive time,
the story of this age is very complicated.
Society did regress in many ways
for many people living in the times.
The world was comparatively darker than
it had been in the past for reasons
which we will discuss. But there
was also a lot going on in his time.
There were many important and great
moments in history which took place in an
age which historians may unfairly scoring
sometimes in the decades following the
fall of Rome. A number of
things happen. Multiple success.
We kingdoms arise in the all
territories of the empire.
This is a map of Europe in a year,
524 years after rung fell.
As you can see, the kingdom's formed by
the Visigoths, the Franks, the Ostrogoths,
the Anglo Saxons,
and the Burgundians are some of the
most important kingdoms following Rome's
fault. Most of the successor kingdoms are
led by dramatic tribes whom the Romans
considered barbarians.
Now,
there is a portrayal of these
kingdoms being formed by savages,
living in huts after having
burned down Roman civilization,
but many of these kingdoms actually
kind of built on top of Rome.
They worked with Roman aristocracy.
They were in many ways, Roman.
A good example of this was out
of whack or his kingdom of Italy.
Actually auto wacker would naturally
make an effort to depose of his Roman
competitors,
but the Roman Senate would
actually continue to function
during his reign and he
drew on their support for a large amount
of power and the state would gradually
join the Ostrow gothic Kanombe as time
went on, which in many ways was as well.
Roman.
Furthermore,
many of these so called barbarians were
as I discussed earlier, rather romanized.
They spoke varieties of Latin,
which was slowly evolve
into other languages like
French, Italian, and Spanish.
Many followed the Roman
religion of Christianity
though for many it was area and
Christianity, which was slightly different
from the Catholic Christianity. A Rome,
regardless the area and Christians in
Italy still heavily respected a Catholic
church centered in a city of Rome.
Many would say that Rome
never truly fell all the way,
but instead it survived.
In the Latin speaking Catholic Church.
During the five hundreds of Frank's
began moving westward from modern day
Belgium into the rest of modern
France. Their leader, Clovis unified,
the Frankish tribes effectively laying
the foundations for the modern nation of
France and the Merovingian Dynasty,
which was to rule it.
He ruled from a city called Paris,
which would now serve as the capital
of his people up to the modern day.
Clovis also converted to Christianity
becoming one of the first northern
Germanic kings to do so, and he required
that as subjects convert as well,
laying the foundation for Catholicism
to spread throughout Europe.
As Europe became increasingly fragmented,
times became harder.
Life became, as is often said,
nasty, brutish and short.
In many ways,
Christianity would be what gave the
people of Europe unity and hope and its
expansion from its Roman origins begins
with these Germanic peoples adopting it.
The Franks, however, we're
politically unable to form a large,
powerful successor state because of
inheritance laws. When Clovis died,
his conquest were divided
again between his four sons.
Control of our power during such divisions
across Europe would be the main cause
for large amounts of conflict that
marked the dark ages. In fact,
in Merovingian France in particular,
they were very constant civil wars.
We may have a hard time imagining how
this many civil wars can be erupting,
but the concept of the state,
as we understand it today,
was not yet present in Europe
in this period of history.
The perspective of the time was that
the country belonged essentially to the
king while post the Roman
Europe was modeled on the
skeleton of the Roman Empire
in important ways. As time passed,
it became more and more clearly,
really just a skeleton.
Trade and infrastructure broke down
relatively quickly and the past
Mediterranean was a Roman Lake,
which connected this Atlanta
allowing trade to flourish.
Now the trade system's broke down
as the roads fell into disuse and a
countryside and sees
became dangerous places,
much of Europe return to the
more localized agricultural
societies that predated
the Roman Empire.
When Rome fell and warfare and plundering
of cities became more constant lower
class workers,
both Roman and barbarian fled to the
countryside to escape it and made deals
with Roman land,
owning aristocrats in exchange for work,
Roman aristocrats,
opera to house and defend them.
A system which would evolve into the
feudal systems that dominated medieval
Europe. While we can debate and discuss
the validity of the term dark ages.
There are many very obviously dark
features of this post Roman world.
As a result of all the
changes we just discussed,
European societies became much smaller
places throughout the centuries following
Rome. Education naturally also fell with
infrastructure and societal stability.
Throughout much of the early ages,
only about 1% of the population,
mostly the clergy could read.
Life expectancy dropped.
The population dropped,
four started to grow back. I knew
Europe became an eerily empty place.
Roman ruins were often
stripped for building supplies.
The Colosseum in Rome served
for a time as a landfill.
The drop in education and the spreading
of information allowed for distant lands
to become mysteries again.
People were regularly nervous
about invaders or plunderers
whom they didn't see
coming. Arriving suddenly on the scene,
the mysterious forest and countrysides,
which were indeed dangerous places,
also became the subjects of folktales and
the early Middle Ages were a source of
many myths and folktales and such things
with which we are still familiar today.
People told tales of Goblins,
ferries, witches, sorcerers, the debt,
etc. And many of those tails while they
were viewed as unacceptable pagan myths
by the dominant Catholic Church still
lasted to stay in certain cases as
original tails, but at least
generally informed, you know,
something like the Lord of the rings.
For example,
while it was written in the 20th century,
much of it was based off of
dark age European mythology.
Life was not all bad for these people's,
but certainly as they lived
among the ruins of Rome,
even the most uneducated had an
understanding that they were living in it,
a graded world compared to the past.
While these kingdoms work to succeed,
Rome in the West and the east,
the light of Rome continued to shine.
The eastern Roman Empire
did not fall with the West.
Rather it evolved into the Byzantine
Empire and though they were Greek speaking
and much more eastern and western,
they continue to view themselves as
a Romans for the next thousand years,
which Byzantium stood on August 1st five
27 the emperor Justinian came to the
throne just sitting in the
great as he came to be called,
had very clear intentions,
which he called run Novato and
Patty the restoration of the empire.
At this point in history,
Rome,
he'd only been gone for about 50 years
and Justinian intended to bring it back
by reconquering Roman territory,
loss of the barbarians after
making a piece with the shop,
the assassin had Persians there bribes.
He turned his forces westward.
The general Bellis Saris invaded the
north African vandal lens and subdued them
within a year, bringing
them into the empire. Next,
he turned his attention to the lens of
the Ostrogoths. Unfortunately for him,
he found much less success there.
It took 20 years rather cause subdue
them and it was a very debilitating
campaign for both sides. And in the
end though, Italy had been reconquered.
Much of it was ruined in a conflict.
The city of Rome, for example,
had been sacked five times
throughout these wars,
firmly bringing them into the darkness
of the Dark Ages along with this failure.
And it was a considerable failure.
You have a cost Byzantium around 300,000
pounds of goal to rebuild Italy and war
with the Persians,
presumed just any,
and also had a rude awakening and
discovering that the societal structure of
Rome had essentially
fallen apart at his time.
And that rebuilding it in the West
after all this time was much more of a
difficult prospect than he had
realized though Byzantium Hell,
Don's the territory's and it seemed,
Rome was making a comeback of sorts.
A plague then suddenly struck Byzantium
known as the plague of Justinian.
This plague was one of
the worst in history.
It killed 13% of the world's population
or about half the population of the
Byzantine Empire. Within a year. Imagine
the effects of half the people you know,
dying within a year.
This is what just [inaudible] was facing
on an empire wide scale and he himself
was eventually struck with the plague.
He was one of the fortunate
ones to survive it,
but it left him scarred and he became
increasingly erratic, tyrannical,
and paranoid.
Moreover though it left the empire
scarred and though Justinian brought about
great things with Byzantium culture,
learning art,
architecture like the highest Sophia,
et Cetera,
the empire was far too irreparably
damaged by this plague to realistically
rebuild the Roman Empire.
It would not be long until Byzantium
slowly started to lose a lens at a
conquered as well as some of
its own original lands as well.
The lombards would start taking control
of northern Italy and later the Persians,
AVRs, Bulgarians, Slavs, et cetera.
We'll close in on the empire as well.
Byzantium gradually contracted in six
26 constant and Nopa was besieged by
Persians AVRs.
The Byzantines would win,
but these wars were indeed fracturing.
The empire.
Ms Fracturing would leave the empire
too weak to defend against what would be
the greatest enemy of the Byzantine
Empire is long and the six thirties Arabic
followers of a new religion.
Islam began their quest for world empire.
They found both Byzantium
and Persia to weaken,
to withstand the assaults and within
a decade had spread and to Egypt,
Iran and the border of Anatolia.
By 780 the Umayyad caliphates stretched
from North Africa to Afghanistan
overtaking the Persians and most of
Byzantium is non European territory.
The Islamic powers founded by the Arabs
and this time have a mixed place in
history.
In some ways,
definitely they would come to be the
enemies of European civilization and the
enemies of what was left to Rome.
In other ways,
they were the successors of
classical civilization in the east.
The Islamic golden age began,
while much of Europe existed
in the aforementioned state
in the eighth century,
and the peoples of this region, Arabs,
north Africans, Persians, et Cetera,
took up science, history,
linguistics, medicine, literature,
philosophy, mathematics,
and many other fields of education. As
Europe was still ruled on her frag method,
successor states the Arabs began
pushing into Hispana and closer towards
Constantinople,
eventually besieging it in seven 17 the
siege of Constantinople was a failure,
however, and that would leave the Arabs
weekend and drink Hispana, however,
was not a failure.
Throughout the eighth century that we,
my odds would move at the modern day,
Spain and Portugal conquering
the territories of the visit,
gothic kingdom and beginning Islamic
rule of the peninsula that would last for
centuries. Meanwhile, in the Frankish
empire, things were changing.
The Merovingian dynasty was losing power
and Muslim forces were moving in across
the pier and ease into modern France
standing in their way. However,
with someone whom the Franks
would call shock Martel,
Martel was old French for Hammer Charles
the hammer and the Mios gonna meet at
the Battle of Tours on
October 10th seven 32 there,
the Franks would score a decisive
victory over the Muslims killing 12,000
including the enemy commander while
taking only 1000 or so losses.
The pope hailed Martell is having saved
Europe from Muslim domination as they
would never attempt to invade
Europe from the Pyrenees again.
Following this spousal Martel's power
would grow enormously if a position is
king, might seem a natural
next step. However,
he was ultimately unable and unwilling
to take that position. Instead,
he organized himself to hold power
and rule from the background.
While Theodoric of the Merovingian
dynasty held the official title.
This was again mainly due
to the importance to Frank's
placed on tradition and
though the monarchy was much
less powerful than it had been,
there were still unwilling to do something
such as overthrowing the monarchy.
They felt it might anger God that it
would be a front to their heritage and
identity as a people et and Martell
newest people would not support him.
For this reason.
It would be his son rather Pepin the
short who would throw the Merovingians and
begin the Carolingian dynasty in France.
He did this to the intervention of the
only person of Frank's felt was hired in
their king.
The pope,
the pope claimed pepins ascension to
the throne was an act of God and few
therefore contested it and turn Kim Pepin
would give the church lens which will
become the papal states known
as the donation of Pepin.
When Pepin died in seven 68 his
son Charles would succeed him.
Charles the first would become one of
the most important rulers of the age
earning the title of the great or
as he is often called Charlemagne.
Charlemagne is sometimes called potter.
I wrote by the father of Europe because
of his many efforts to reinvigorate and
United Europe. After his brother died,
he would unite his Frankish kingdom.
He would then invade northern Italy,
Germany,
the Netherlands part of Eastern Europe,
and even extend into the Balkans and part
of Spain and above all he would have a
lot of success in doing so.
He would fight all throughout his life
to achieve this along with territorial
and political aspirations.
Charlemagne with the support and the
pope was also heavily preoccupied with
spreading Christianity.
Charlemagne insisted that the Saxons
of modern day Germany convert to
Catholicism and those who refused were
killed and one example 4,500 Saxons were
executed and what is remembered as
the massacre of her den. Accordingly,
much of his empire rapidly
became Christianized.
Charlemagne sought not only to expand his
empire but to enlighten it from within
as well.
And so he wasn't concerned only with
bringing political and religious unity to
Europe, but made efforts to restore Europe
to the intellectuals. Social cultural,
infrastructural power of the Roman days
to the point at which his reign is often
called the Carolinian renaissance.
He would invite his empire
into a number of counties,
a constantly travel throughout Europe
to make sure his subordinates were
following his orders in an age when only
around 1% of the population could read.
Charlemagne insisted education
was a key to revitalizing Europe.
He himself learned how to
read and demanded it of other
officials and statesman.
He built schools across the continent
which increased educational opportunities
not only for the wealthy,
but even the lower classes as well.
This fire of learning,
which spread throughout Europe would
help the continent restore trade and
infrastructure.
The Unity Charlemagne had achieved for
the more allowed for disinterested in
such things to be realistic again, and
the roads were prioritized and guarded.
Charlemagne had United much
of Europe Christianize.
It brought education and learning to it,
rebuilt its infrastructure and on the
whole improved life for those within his
nation.
On Christmas Day and the year 800 a
Charlemagne knelt at the altar to pray at
mass in Saint Peter's Pope Leo,
the third place a crown on his head
and proclaimed him emperor of Rome.
There is debate actually about whether
or not Charlemagne knew that this was
going to happen.
He later claimed that if he did know,
he wouldn't have even
gone into the church,
but most historians find it hard to
believe that he had no idea that this was
going to happen. And in fact, he
didn't exactly dislike the title.
Considering in official documents,
he preferred to be styled Carlis
Serani seamless. I ghost this ideo,
not this magnus [inaudible] imperium,
meaning Charles Most Serene,
Augustus crowned by God the great
peaceful emperor ruling the Roman Empire,
as one might expect.
The Byzantines were not very fun of this.
They tended to regard western Europeans
as uneducated on civilized barbarian be
surfers, and more importantly,
the empress. Irene,
a Byzantium considered herself.
There were live Rome,
not this Frankish barbarian Charlemagne.
Now this was much more than just
a petty debate over a title.
It was another example of strain between
Byzantium and the Catholic Church. This,
along with conflict over land claims
in Italy would lead to a war between
Byzantium and Charlemagne,
but it would end with land agreements and
the Byzantines recognizing Charlemagne
as emperor,
though not exactly emperor of Rome.
As time went on,
however,
the divide between east and West would
only deepen what seemed like Europe was
beginning.
A streak of recovery,
external and internal forces will begin
to wreak havoc on Trello means empire.
Western Europe was about to being close
upon on three sides from the south
Islamic north African pirates who begin
rating and plundering southern Europe
from the east.
A terrifying wave of nomadic warriors
from Asia known as a Magyars would begin
pushing in and from the north,
perhaps the most fearsome of all,
a group of pagans, Scandinavian
Raiders, known as the Vikings,
would seek plunder and
opportunity in Europe.
Charlemagne would go to war with a
Danish Vikings and eight oh wait,
but made peace and eight 11 I've done
an in depth documentary on the vikings
already on my channel as a matter of fact,
but essentially the vikings were,
as I said, a group of Scandinavian
Raiders from Modern Day Denmark,
Sweden and Norway that is
send it on Europe in the
late 18th century on June 8th
seven 93 on an island known as Linda's
foreign and the Kingdom of Northumbria
and Monterey England,
a group of Raiders,
assaulted and undefended Abby slaughtering
and slaving anyone in their way.
This was not necessarily the
first viking rate in history,
but it is perhaps the most notable as it
marked the beginning of the Viking age
terror spread throughout
Europe of the brutal Northmen.
Why the Vikings came is still a
matter of debate. The vikings were,
as I said,
Pagans and the peg and Saxons who had
been slaughtered by Charlemagne earlier.
We're just south of Denmark,
so they may have felt concerned about
the violence spread of Christianity and
they certainly as a result
did not like to Frank's.
There was also perhaps a population boom
at this time in Scandinavia and there
were an excess number of
landless men as a result,
and of course it's a constant theme
throughout his Sri that large numbers of
landless jobless young men tend
to go out and cause trouble,
especially when you factor in that there
was potentially a shortage of females
in the region because of
female infanticide at birth.
May Norris at the time wanted their
firstborn is to be males. A main factor,
however,
was likely simply because they could.
Europe was becoming wealthier at this
time and opportunity for plunder started
displaying itself, especially on
coastal cities and cities along rivers.
The Vikings,
through their advanced naval technology,
exploited this opportunity attacking coast
and even sailing up rivers with large
groups of men,
namely with the long boat design,
which was unheard of prior to this point.
The sailing abilities of the vikings
meant simply nowhere was safe.
They could sail inland France and Germany.
They could sail to distant lands going
as far as North Africa and Byzantium,
but their favorite target was right next
to home. The British isles as islands.
Very few locations on the British isles
where more than just a few days march
from the sea and as the
Viking age progressed,
there would be more and more Viking
influence in Britain and Ireland.
A few years later in eight 14
in the face of all this chaos,
Charlemagne died at the age
of 71 Charlemagne had had
four sons and throughout
his life expected he would have
to divide his empire among them.
Unfortunately for him, but fortunately
for the Carolingian Empire,
only one of them, Louis outlived him
and the empire pass to him. However,
regardless,
much of Louise Rain was marked by civil
war and conflict and when he died his
empire was divided among
his sons in a year,
eight 43 three years after his death and
the west of territory would be ruled by
Charles and the East
Louie and in the center.
Loath are these divisions would
form the basis of France, Germany,
and the low countries in such places
that remained to this day that a vision
between these kings only encourage
the enemies of Christian Europe.
The Vikings would increase their rates,
Muslims would increase their plundering.
Taking slaves in Luton
such things as well,
and the Magyars closed in in some places.
People were hit by all three of these
foes in such times when the central
political figures of Europe
would invited and wore,
people would turn to the protection of
the local Nobel's marking some of the
beginnings of standard European feudalism.
In eight 65 the vikings took
a new step to their approach.
A great army of Vikings landed on the
coast of North Umbria and Anglo Saxon
Kingdom and Modern Day England known to
the Anglo Saxons as the great heathen
army.
They did not come to raid,
but in fact to settle gradually
absorbing lands in England,
starting with the city of York,
which they called the orvick.
Gradually the Anglo Saxon lands would fall
to the Dane law. Standing against him,
however, was the ruler of the Kingdom of
Wessex in southern England named Alfred.
In time,
he would become to known as the great.
He would spend much of his reign
in conflict with the Vikings,
but he would say the last free
kingdoms of England from Viking role,
though much of the island would remain
under Norse rural for centuries with
Alfred at the head of these kingdoms, he
was style himself, not king of Wessex,
but instead King of England laying the
foundations for things that come in the
late 19th and early 10th centuries,
the Magyars who begin to form a
kingdom and central eastern Europe,
a nation which would come
to be known as Hungary.
This kingdom would plunder Europe for
decades to come invading both the western
and eastern world and becoming a specific
nuisance to the East Franks as well as
the Bulgarians and the
Byzantines and nine 55 however,
as the Magyars pressed further into lens
that will become Germany, the king auto,
the first would oppose them.
He met them at the battle of Lek felled
that year under autos command was a new
type of soldier,
heavy cavalry,
an important force in standing up
against a horse warriors. The Magyars,
this heavy cavalry would go on to form
the foundation of Medieval Knights.
Auto would win,
repelling the Hungarians and in the eyes
of Catholic Europe being an offender of
Christendom as auto continued to work to
unite the German tribes and expand his
empire,
he will be crowned in a similar manner
as Charlemagne by the pope being titled,
Holy Roman Emperor. Thus the holy
Roman empire was born. Meanwhile,
the Vikings often regarded
as destroyers of Europe.
We're in many other ways giving birth
to parts of it and going far beyond what
their opponents were doing.
Many would integrate into European
societies and convert to Catholicism in
France.
In order to appease the vikings,
the king would give them land on
the northern part of the country,
which would come to be known as a
land of the north men or Normandy.
These Normans,
after integrating with a French,
would go on to conquer England a century
later and lay the foundations for the
English monarchy. They're having the
greatest naval technology in Europe.
They would go on to explore and
settled distant lands reaching Iceland,
Greenland,
and even North America.
Discovering it's centuries before
Columbus and eastern Europe.
The Vikings would come to claim territory
and rule a Slavic people as an ability.
These vikings known as the reus would
lay the foundations for modern Russia,
even as far east as Byzantium,
the emperor of Constantinople observing
their military prowess hired them to be
as personal bodyguard known
as the Bahrainian Card.
Ironically the vikings who brought such
darkness in Europe in the what helped
bring it out of that darkness into
the Higher Middle Ages which followed
ultimately.
However,
the truly most unifying force in medieval
Europe for perhaps good and bad was
Christianity and the Catholic Church.
The Catholic Church would stamp out
ideas which contradicted his doctrine,
but it would also be responsible
for encouraging a return
of education to Europe.
The church would heavily persecute
those who did not fall into the line of
thought, but oftentimes that meant
persecuting rapists, thieves,
murderers and other nefarious people.
Leaders would be held under a degree
of rule from the Catholic church,
which was an plenty of circumstances,
a self interested organization.
The Catholic Church was also instrumental
in restricting self interested rulers
and ability and held them to a
standard of decency and morality.
The Catholic Church would encourage
the code of chivalry among Europeans,
which turned the medieval knight from a
barbarian thug into a servant of piety
and morality.
We can debate the effects that religion
and especially religious organizations
have on people,
especially in times like the dark ages,
and we can even call into question how
much good and bad that the Catholic
Church did in his time was really in
the name of religion or if it was out of
his self interested plot.
But in the end,
I think it would be fair to say that
the Catholic Church played a significant
role of bringing Europe
out of the dark ages,
even if that role was not wholly good
or bad in the eyes of some historians,
Europe would not return to the same level
of appreciation and dignity until the
renaissance. But around the
beginning of the 11th century,
the dark age of the Medieval world
was coming to a close trade and
infrastructure where we're turning to
former grander art and architecture.
Took off modern nation states,
notably England, France,
Poland in Denmark,
saw their foundations in his time and
with those nations can the concept of the
state and the power which they would
come to wield the first crusades,
would reintroduce Europe to
the intellectual achievements
of antiquity and the
Islamic golden age,
which were crucial in pulling Europe from
the Middle Ages all together and into
the modern world.
The modern world,
which by the 11th and 12th centuries
was beginning to come into sight.
As for the Roman Empire,
it would never truly rise again.
The Byzantine Empire would survive until
the 15th century when Constantinople
was finally captured by the
Muslim Ottoman Empire in Europe,
many from the holy Roman Empire to
Napoleonic France to Mussolini's,
Italy would claim to be the
return of the Roman Empire.
And though none would ever be truly Roman,
the legacy of the Romans would
last up to the modern day.
But while Rome laid the foundations for
much of Europe and significant parts of
the world,
in fact,
we should not forget that many
other important foundations
lie in the efforts of
the people who push through and survived.
A very dark age at this time.
I'd like to thank Jonathan Trillo
for is Patriot and support.
For more videos like this and
videos on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire of learning
and subscribe. Thank you for watching.